Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field, the principles can work for you.
大家好，我是玛丽安。在切入今天的节目之前，我想快速向大家预告一件现在正在发生的美妙事情。如果你曾纳闷如何创造适合自己的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会爱上由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主办的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，这些原则都对你适用。
There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent and saying really lovely things about the podcast. Thank you for subscribing and sharing it with your network. It is so greatly appreciated. Today I'm going to be thinking with you about history taking
此外，还有由丽莎亲自颁发的丰厚奖品等你来赢取。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南吧。与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起，感谢大家对本期节目的喜爱，并对播客说了很多暖心的话。感谢你们的订阅并将其分享给你们的社交圈。这真的非常感激。今天我想和大家探讨的是病史采集，
in a way that doesn't just feel like an onslaught and doesn't feel like it's just really hard work for you and really invasive for the client that you're spending time with. So yeah, let me see how well I can do this on an audio podcast. I feel like it might be a little bit better presented with a PowerPoint or a Canva or something, but I will try and use my very best describing ways for you. Now let's also just think about which discipline of psychology you are going to be striving for. I believe that good history taking is appropriate to all disciplines, be that clinical or counselling, forensic, health, counselling, education. You know, the world is your oyster but I think that really good history taking in a way that does feel human is so important. So I really like this question because it shows us the attunement
这种采集方式不会让人感觉像是一场狂轰滥炸，不会让你觉得只是在做极其繁重的工作，也不会让与你共度的客户感到极具侵入性。所以，是的，让我看看我如何在音频播客中把这一点做好。我觉得如果能配合幻灯片、Canva 或其他什么东西展示，可能会呈现得更好一点，但我会尽力用我最好的描述方式为您讲解。现在，让我们也来思考一下你将要为之努力的心理学学科。我相信，优秀的病史采集适用于所有学科，无论是临床还是咨询、法医、健康、咨询、教育。你知道，世界是广阔的，但我认为以一种充满人情味的方式进行非常出色的病史采集是极其重要的。所以我真的很喜欢这个问题，因为它向我们展示了同频共振，
and being on board with how it feels for a client and this is absolutely something that I have gone through myself as well in my kind of metamorphosis, shall we say, as a developing clinician, because we're always developing. There's always better and different ways to do things. Every day is a school day and we're never going to be complete. You know, we can always change and adapt and grow and, you know know hear really great ways of doing things and think I am having that. Don't let that be daunting though because we do learn to to be good enough but you know when you work in this mental health field and you see practice that really connects with you it's okay to borrow that and to kind of bring that into your fold of the way that you work and the way
并且理解客户的感受，这绝对是我自己在成长为临床医生的“蜕变”（我们可以这样称呼它）过程中也经历过的，因为我们总是在不断发展。总有更好、不同的做事方法。活到老学到老，我们永远不会完美。你知道的，我们总是可以改变、适应和成长，你知道的，听到真正很棒的做事方式，然后觉得“我要把这个学过来”。不过，不要因此而感到气馁，因为我们确实学会了做到“足够好”，但你知道，当你在这个心理健康领域工作，看到真正能与你产生共鸣的实践时，去借鉴它并将其融入你自己的工作方式以及你
that you aspire to be with people. It might be just worth telling you that in my private practice, what I do in terms of outcome measures is I send those in advance of the appointment. I use a clinical note system called write up, but it might be that whichever organisation you work in, there's also some sort of electronic form giving capacity so it means you can send those questionnaires in advance and then have the person send them back to you before the appointment and why I like that because it allows me to screen for risk you know as a rudimentary measure and to look at you know look at getting those scored ahead of the session and my virtual assistant will pop them into a whizzy spreadsheet for me and it also automatically creates graphs so
渴望如何与人相处的方式中，是没有问题的。也许值得告诉大家的是，在我的私人诊所里，关于结果测量，我通常会在预约前把这些表格发过去。我使用的是一个叫 Write Up 的临床笔记系统，不过无论你在哪个机构工作，也可能存在某种电子表格发放功能，这意味着你可以提前发送这些问卷，然后让对方在预约前将其发回给你。我为什么喜欢这样做呢？因为它允许我进行风险筛查，你知道的，作为一种基础的测量手段，并在会诊前查看这些问卷的评分情况，我的虚拟助理会把它们录入一个很棒的电子表格中，它还会自动生成图表，所以
at the assessment I can show these graphs to the person and we can talk them through together but maybe you know if it's at all possible in your job plan, even if there are paper questionnaires, whether you've perhaps got a junior member of the team who could phone the client in advance and do those questionnaires with the client so that you're using your time together with the client optimally. You know, people don't always attend appointments. You might have had a DNA and you'd have this data then that relates to the patient and they haven't shown up. But there's always ways for thinking about how you can get that data without you having to use your valuable clinical time with people to read those questionnaires. Because actually, that's what I hate. People don't like it very much either. I'm a skilled clinician and I'm sure you are too and actually it's just not good good use of my time or the client's time to have me read all those questions aloud but whether you know they might want to get there early to do those
在评估时，我可以把这些图表展示给对方，我们可以一起讨论；但也许，如果在你的工作计划中完全可行的话，即使是纸质问卷，你手下也许有比较年轻的团队成员可以提前打电话给客户，并与客户一起完成这些问卷，这样你就能以最佳方式利用你和客户在一起的时间。你知道，人们并不总是按时参加预约。你可能会遇到爽约（DNA）的情况，而你手里就会有与这位患者相关的数据，虽然他们没有露面。但总有办法思考如何获取这些数据，而不需要占用你与人们相处的宝贵临床时间来阅读那些问卷。因为实际上，这也是我所讨厌的。大家其实也不太喜欢这样。我是一位熟练的临床医生，我相信你也是，实际上，让我把所有这些问题大声朗读出来，并不是对我或客户时间的最好利用。不过，如果他们可能想早点来完成这些
questionnaires so maybe you can give them an earlier time but of course if the client is having to do those on that day then it might take them outside of their window of tolerance too so it's thinking about the best way of doing that but in terms of the actual session content for history taking and for initial assessments I'll take you through the approach that I use so I don't actually use pre-filled or pre-formatted forms. I like to go a bit old school. I like a bit of A3 paper. So I like to, for each client that I assess and each that I treat, I like to have this A3 piece of paper. And when I'm with them, I go through what gender they see themselves as. And so I draw the appropriate shape, either a circle or a square. And I think the non-binary shape is a diamond, but I might be wrong.
问卷，也许你可以给他们安排一个更早的时间，但当然，如果客户必须在当天完成这些问卷，这也可能会超出他们的容忍窗口（window of tolerance），所以这就需要思考这样做的最佳方式。不过，就病史采集和初次评估的实际会话内容而言，我将带大家了解我所使用的方法。实际上，我并使用预先填好或格式化的表格。我喜欢走复古路线。我喜欢 A3 纸。因此，对于我评估的每个客户和治疗的每个人，我都喜欢准备这张 A3 纸。当我和他们在一起时，我会过一遍他们认同的性别。因此，我画出相应的形状，要么是圆形，要么是方形。我想非二元性别的形状是一个菱形，但我可能记错了。
Let me know if I am. So I would draw that and I draw that in the middle of the page. I'd put their name and their age in the shape too. And I'd be thinking with them about people in their family so just looking really to draw a basic family tree and as I'm just doing that on my lap people are talking and at the beginning of the session I would explain to the client that I'm with that I'll be making some notes as we talk and it's just to help me remember because actually as a result of today I'm going
如果我记错了请告诉我。所以我会画出这个形状，把它画在页面中间。我也会把他们的名字和年龄写在形状里面。我会和他们一起思考他们家庭中的成员，也就是着手绘制一个基本的家谱。当我把这些画在膝盖上时，人们正在说话。在会话开始时，我会向与我在一起的客户解释，我们交谈时我会做一些笔记，这只是为了帮我记住，因为实际上，今天结束之后我要
to be writing a report an assessment report and I want to make sure that I'm remembering it well enough but I'll be doing it in such a way that if you want to know what I'm writing at any point please do just let me know and I'm not writing big things I'm just writing notes to help me remember but please if you did want to ask at any point or you wondered what I was writing or why I'd written it I'm really okay with it being a transparent process so please do feel free to ask. So once I'm padding out my family tree I'm looking to work out if their parents are still alive, if they've got any siblings, if their grandparents are alive, if there have been any significant bereavements and who they feel closest to, if anyone. And also it's always really
写一份报告，一份评估报告，我想确保自己能把这些记下来，但我记录的方式是，如果你在任何时候想知道我写了什么，请务起告诉我。我写的不是什么大部头，我只是在做笔记来帮助自己记忆，但拜托，如果你在任何时候想问，或者你想知道我写了什么，以及我为什么这样写，我完全支持这是一个透明的过程，所以请随时提问。因此，当我不断丰富我的家谱时，我希望弄清楚他们的父母是否仍然在世，他们是否有兄弟姐妹，祖父母是否健在，是否有过任何重大的丧亲之痛，以及他们觉得和谁最亲近（如果有的话）。此外，询问任何宠物或任何非常重要的朋友或阿姨、叔叔，那些属于他们的“战队”、站在他们这一边的人，也总是非常
important to ask about any pets or any really important friends or aunts or uncles, people that are kind of on their team, that feel like they're on their page. And people often don't expect you to be asking these questions and often asking about strengths too things that are going well in their lives and I'd usually follow the same pattern so the top left of my document would be my kind of problem focused section and it usually crops up in conversation I might say to them so you know what what brought you here today because I often don't know anything about clients before I meet them. And even when I was in the NHS service, I sometimes wouldn't want to read too much about clients. So I knew they'd been through the triage
重要。人们通常不会指望你会问这些问题，而且通常也会询问优势——也就是他们生活中进展顺利的事情。我通常会遵循相同的模式：我的文档左上角是我所谓的“问题聚焦”部分，这通常会在谈话中出现。我可能会对他们说：“那么，是什么把你带到这里来的呢？”因为我在见到客户之前通常对他们一无所知。甚至当我在 NHS（英国国民健保署）服务时，有时我也不想阅读太多关于客户的信息。因此，我知道他们已经通过了分诊
process, and they were deemed as being likely to benefit from a psychology assessment. But I like to hear from clients at the time that the client tells me which could also I guess be a bit frustrating for clients too because they're like oh no I've already told someone all of this I was hoping you'd know already but yeah I think there is value in giving people the experience to tell you things themselves so I've been looking at the problems and also thinking about the goals goals would usually be top right for me what they're aiming to get out of therapy or treatment, what would feel useful and the strengths is between those two. So if we're looking at my piece of A3, we've got problems on the left, top right is goals and then next to goals I would have strengths,
流程，并且被认为很可能会从心理学评估中受益。但我喜欢在客户告诉我的时候听他们讲述，这其实对客户来说也可能有点沮丧，因为他们会想：“噢，不，我已经把这一切都告诉过别人了，我本希望你已经知道了。”但是的，我认为给人们一个机会亲自把事情告诉你是有价值的。所以我一直在观察问题，同时也思考目标。目标对我来说通常在右上角，也就是他们想从治疗中获得什么，什么会让他们觉得有用，而优势则介于这两者之间。因此，如果我们看我的 A3 纸，左边是问题，右上角是目标，然后在目标旁边我会有优势，
next along from that to the left there'd be medication and also a column for self-soothing so that might be really adaptive things like going for a walk or some yoga or mindfulness or meditation but it might also include slightly less adaptive techniques like smoking alcohol or self-harm so whatever helps them get through each day currently but of course you know i'm exploring these in a way that feels non-judgmental so absolutely going with the stance that there's no judgment here and actually we understand these methods as just being able to get through each day the best we can with the resources we've got and on some days we might
再往左一点，会有药物栏，还有一个用于自我安抚的栏目。这可能是非常具有适应性的事情，比如散步、瑜伽、正念或冥想，但它也可能包括一些适应性稍差的技巧，比如吸烟、酗酒或自残。总之，不管是什么能帮助他们撑过每一天的方法。当然，你知道的，我正在以一种不带批判色彩的方式探索这些，所以绝对要持“这里没有批判”的立场，事实上，我们理解这些方法只是为了用我们手头仅有的资源尽最大努力撑过每一天。有时我们可能
have more resources or we might be better resourced than other days and just trying to explore with them really thinking about that window of tolerance and trying to think about ways we might be able to help them thicken and broaden that window of tolerance. Let's think some more about this assessment and history-taking after this brief advert. This book is a chance to be supported in grief And to learn how to support one another Over 50 stories written by those that are grieved They've been there too, so they know how you suffer It's the Grief Collective
拥有更多资源，或者与其它日子相比，我们拥有更好的资源储备。我们要真正尝试与他们一起探索，考虑到那个容忍窗口，并试着寻找能够帮助他们加固和拓宽容忍窗口的方法。在这段简短的广告之后，让我们继续思考这项评估和病史采集。这本书是一次在悲伤中获得支持的机会，并学习如何彼此支持。由50多位经历过悲伤的人撰写的故事，他们也曾经历过，所以他们知道你如何痛苦。这就是“悲伤集体”（The Grief Collective）
Stories of life lost and learning to heal The Grief Collective Written by people who get how you feel I love the Grief Collective book. It really helped me to realise that what I've been going through with grief isn't entirely normal. I loved being part of the collective whilst I read the book and it was such a privilege to have such intimate access into people's lives, thoughts and feelings. I would recommend it to anyone
失去生命的挚爱与学会治愈的故事。悲伤集体。由那些懂得你感受的人撰写。我喜欢《悲伤集体》这本书。它真的帮助我意识到，我所经历的悲伤并不是完全不正常的。在阅读这本书的同时，能够成为这个集体的一员，我感到非常荣幸，能够如此深入地了解人们的生活、思想和感受，这真是一种特权。我会把它推荐给任何
wanting to understand themselves or someone they care about. Thank you. Stories of life lost and learning to heal. The Grief Collective. Written by people who get how you feel. Okay, welcome back. So what we are doing is we're building up a picture of the difficulties that the person has had and then their relationship to those difficulties. I'd also have a section for thinking about previously tried, you know, therapies or psychology input. So if they've already had a year of counselling or 20 sessions of CBT, then I'll be putting that down as well. I'd also be asking them about their opinion for how it went and whether it's informed
想要了解自己或他们关心的人的人。谢谢。失去生命的挚爱与学会治愈的故事。悲伤集体。由那些懂得你感受的人撰写。好的，欢迎回来。所以我们正在做的是，逐步勾勒出这个人所遭遇的困难，以及他们与这些困难的关系。我还会设立一个板块，用来思考之前尝试过的疗法或心理学干预。因此，如果他们已经进行了为期一年的咨询，或者进行了20次认知行为疗法（CBT），我也会把这些写下来。我还会询问他们对治疗效果的看法，以及它是否
their choice for a future therapy, you know, a future whatever we've got on, whatever you're assessing for. And I would also have a section for ideas. So as we're talking, I might scribble down an idea, for example, if I notice they're being really harsh on themselves, then I'd likely scribble down a CFT book or you know a group that we might have running so this is when I come to to summarize at the end of our session that I've already got you know my informed thinking about what I think might be a reasonable plan so that we're able to send them away with a plan that feels helpful. Of course risk is key but if you've covered the questionnaire and
影响了他们对未来疗法的选择（不管是未来的什么疗法，或是你正在评估的任何项目）。我还会设立一个“想法”板块。在交谈时，我可能会匆匆记下一个想法，例如，如果我注意到他们对自己非常严苛，那么我很可能会随手记下一本关于慈悲焦点疗法（CFT）的书，或者我们可能正在开设的小组。因此，当我在会话结束时进行总结时，我已经有了关于我认为可能是合理计划的知情思考，这样我们就能让他们带着一个觉得有帮助的计划离开。风险当然是关键，但如果你已经完成了问卷和
the things beforehand then you'd have an idea of risk too but in terms of coping strategies risk often comes up too so this is you know I hope a useful approach for you and obviously you need to adhere to whatever your service is asking you to do. if you've got certain hoops then you're going to need to make sure you're jumping through those in regard to what questions and boxes need ticking and fulfilling whatever you've been asked to achieve you know for what your service is funded to to strive for so I think doing that sensitively and being transparent about that with the client is really helpful and the way that I would do that is I'm really sorry I know this can feel like a bit of a deluge of questions and it can I know people have told me it can feel a little bit intrusive but the way we're funded and the way that we have to keep our records means that I need to ask everybody the same questions.
之前的事情，那么你对风险也会有所了解。不过就应对策略而言，风险也经常会出现。所以我希望这对你来说是一种有用的方法，显然你需要遵守你的服务机构要求你做的任何事情。如果你有一些必须履行的程序，那么你需要确保自己按照要求完成了这些问题和复选框，以实现你的服务机构获得资助所要达到的目标。我认为以敏感的方式做到这一点，并对客户保持透明是非常有帮助的。我的做法是：“真的很抱歉，我知道这感觉像是一场狂轰滥炸的问题，而且确实如此。我知道有人告诉过我，这可能会让人觉得有点具有侵入性，但我们获得资金的方式以及我们必须保存记录的方式意味着我需要问每个人相同的问题。”
And so that's how I'd handle it. But if you've got any other questions about how to do this, I'd be really happy to answer them. And to think with you again about the way we can do this in a way that feels like you're on the same page as the client and not kind of on an opposing team, not just like you're hiding behind a clipboard, because I think that can feel really challenging both for you and for the clients that you're working with. So it's just brought to mind for me something that we call the single session intervention. So I don't tend to do assessments just for assessment's sake, but I'd often use aspects from the Our Tricky Brain kit which you can find out more information about on my website or in the show notes to help clients to understand why they feel the way they feel and to think with them about useful stuff that they can take away
这就是我处理的方式。但是，如果你对如何做到这一点还有任何其他问题，我将非常高兴为你解答。并再次与你一起思考，如何以一种让你感觉与客户在同一战线上，而不是在对立阵营中，不像是躲在文件夹后面，因为我认为这无论对你还是对你合作的客户来说都是非常具有挑战性的。这让我想起了我们称之为“单次干预”（single session intervention）的方法。因此，我往往不会为了评估而评估，但我经常会使用“我们棘手的大脑工具包”（Our Tricky Brain kit）中的元素，你可以在我的网站或节目简介中找到关于它的更多信息，以帮助客户理解他们为什么会有这样的感受，并与他们一起思考他们可以带走的有用东西，
from the session. So I might teach them a breathing technique or think with them about the window of tolerance, stuff that they can actually you know leave our session feeling like they're in a better a stronger position than they were when they entered the building because often even to get to a psychology assessment you've already had to perhaps have a team assessment or some other kind of assessment from a triage service you might already have had a long wait and you might have an even longer wait to come or it might be that you don't actually meet the criteria for intervention so isn't it great that if you've got you know an ability to feel better from you know 60 to 90 minutes with someone that's a really special chance that we get with people to get it right so it might feel like
也就是从会话中获得的收获。我可以教他们一种呼吸技巧，或者和他们一起思考容忍窗口，这些东西实际上能让他们离开我们的会话时，感觉自己处于比进门时更好、更强大的位置。因为通常情况下，甚至为了进行心理学评估，你可能已经不得不接受团队评估或分诊服务的其他某种评估，你可能已经等待了很长时间，而且你可能还要等待更长时间，或者你可能根本不符合干预的标准。所以，如果你能通过与某人相处 60 到 90 分钟而感觉好一点，这是一件多么棒的事啊！这是我们与人们接触并把它做好的一个非常特殊的机遇，所以这可能会让人觉得
you've already said everything that feels pertinent. You might not want to be saying it all again. So whether you can use your history taking your assessment session to test out actually how able and capable they are to access the kind of stuff that you'd be having on offer when they actually started to receive the services from you or your service. So if you're trying to do loads of breathing with them or distress tolerance or mindfulness and they just can't do it they don't get it then actually it's maybe an indication that maybe your service isn't going to meet their needs in the way that might be optimal for them at this time so i hope this will be useful and if it is
你已经说完了所有觉得相关的事情。你可能不想把这一切再重复一遍。因此，你可以利用你的病史采集或评估会话，来实际测试他们在实际开始接受你或你的机构提供的服务时，获取你将要提供的这类内容的能力和水平。因此，如果你试图和他们一起做大量的呼吸练习、情绪耐受或正念，而他们根本做不到、无法理解，那么这可能是一个迹象：也许你的服务无法在此时以对他们最优化合意的方式满足他们的需求。所以，我希望这会有所帮助。如果确实如此，
please do rate and review and subscribe and I will look forward to catching up with you on our next podcast episode very soon take care of you if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories
请务必评分、评论并订阅，我非常期待很快在我们的下一期播客节目中与大家见面。照顾好自己。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将迈向获得资格的道路。这里是玛丽安博士的“有抱负的心理学家”。我叫亚娜，我是一名心理健康实习从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事的内容真的非常有趣，
and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及人们是如何成为临床医生的。通往那里的路线竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊讶，成为临床医生并没有什么完美的方式。这让我充满了信心，让我知道我没有做错，并减轻了我自己的压力。因此，如果你对成为一名临床医生感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书了。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。